Alors, il est bon mon rôti ?
C'est excellent.
Toujours été un vrai cordon bleu!
Eh ben, tu féliciteras la bonne parce que c'est pas moi qui l'ai fait.
Aah, j'adore, vous êtes trop drôle mamie.
Oh, profites ma grosse...
... Parce que mamie, elle en a plus pour longtemps.
Faut pas dire ça maman.
Ola maman, ça va ?
Oui... ça va...
C'est passé.
Tu nous as fait peur hein !
Maman ?
Mamie ?
Bon ok...Pas de panique.
Je crois qu'il reste du Champagne.
Je prends les meubles du salon.
Et moi je prends l'argenterie.
C'est moi le fils, c'est moi qui décide.
Alors nous on prend tous les tableaux et la bagnole...
Vous le reste, vous vous démerdez.
Chérie... Les bagouses !
Je veux les bagouses !
Hey ! C'est pas fini !
Bande de chiens !
On plaisantait maman.
En tout cas c'est vraiment bon. C'est quoi la sauce ?
Ta gueule !
Parles pas comme ça à ta grand mère.
S'il te plaît !